bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 week end
l'émission consacrée à vos loisirs et
visité deux sorties alors au programme
du sport du cinéma et un zoom sur les
yvelinois au salon de l'agriculture qui
se tient jusqu'à dimanche mais tout de
suite place à notre première invitée il
est venu nous parler des animations à
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
vincent couteau bonjour alors vous êtes
le responsable animation ali le loisir
de saint quentin en yvelines alors ce
week-end il ya deux temps forts d
initiation gratuite au golf et des
portes ouvertes à la réserve naturelle
on peut peut-être commencer par le golfe
pourquoi pas donc effectivement le golfe
propose régulièrement des initiations
gratuites avant de ces grandes journées
portes ouvertes qui auront lieu fin mars
donc vous êtes encadré par un
professionnel qui vous fait pratiquer un
petit peu de practice et puis après vous
allez sur sur un trophée un petit peu de
proches de trousseaux permet de
découvrir l'activité de découvrir que
quelques of vraiment accessible à tous
est vraiment sympathique et puis
derrière vous avez d'explications sur
sûr que vous vous inscrire évidemment
très bien initiation donc au foot heures
comme on l'appelle peut-être potter
c'est mettre la balle dans le trou avec
exactement le club tout plat et le
practice les deux très bien et c'est
gratuit et c'est gratuit il suffit
d'appeler de réserver auprès du golf
blue green et vous aurez votre
inscription très bien peut-être parlé
des travaux ce moment il ya des travaux
à lille de loisirs ce que pour vous en
dire un petit peu plus oui je pense que
tous les usagers de lille qui viennent
en ce moment se rendent compte que c'est
un peu compliqué d'y accéder mais c'est
c'est pour leur bien puisque on réalise
enfin les travaux d'accès ont refait
complètement l'accès donc les golfeurs
sont d'autant plus heureux qu'ils auront
une voie dédiée ou noir en fait
maintenant quatre voies d'entrée contre
une à l'origine et devoirs sortie et
services un projet qui nous tient à
coeur parce que ça fait plusieurs années
qu'on l'avait vous voulez le réaliser
l'ancien président avait déjà pour
hackers ce projet là donc on est content
que ça se réalise et me permettra de
deux d'éviter un peu les bouchons de cas
sur les beaux jours et puis maintenant
on aura plusieurs moyens de paiement
cartes bleues cartes sans contact
espèces ça va faciliter les choses les
travaux sont en cours actuellement oui
tout à fait ils seront terminés pour la
fin mars la fin mars c'est pour bientôt
deuxième temps fort ce week-end
profitez-en la réserve naturelle ouvre
ses portes gratuitement
c'est ça contrairement c'est vrai qu'au
reste de l'île de loisirs elle n'est pas
en accès libre habituellement non
effectivement je sais pas si les saint
quentinois savon à un joyau
environnementale juste aux portes aux
portes de 50 ans au sein de 50 ans est
donc c'est la réserve naturelle
nationale il faut savoir que c'est le
plus haut degré de protection des
réserves naturelles de réserve naturelle
nationale elle est aussi classée natura
2000 au niveau européen et donc c'est un
espace qui est entièrement clos et donc
l'équipe de la réserve composée de
scientifiques d'animateurs ouvre ses
portes nous permet d'y accéder nous
demain c'est de 9h30 à 13h30 en accès
libre fondé sa paire de jumelles une
petite paire de bottes c'est bien en ce
moment et puis voilà ils sont à
disposition pour répondre à quelques
questions sur cet espace là c'est
l'occasion est également ce week-end le
restaurant de loisirs ouvre ses portes à
tout à fait le restaurant les alizés qui
a fermé pendant les verts donc avec ses
grandes baies vitrées face à l'étang
donc je vous invite à découvrir la
nouvelle carte voilà vous avez aussi une
possibilité de restauration au niveau du
golfe bloqués ce week end également il
ya bien sûr toutes les activités en
libre accès et il y en a pas mal le
temps risque de ne pas être au beau fixe
mais il ya toujours les jeux de plein
air les manèges le trampoline les vélos
aussi à disposition également des
parcours d'orientation qui sont proposés
oui tout à fait c'est accessible aussi
bien pour les familles pour les groupes
que d'une façon puis balade ou alors une
façon beaucoup plus sportive en course
d'orientation et cette année on a même
un nouveau un nouveau produit on a mis
en place l'année dernière c'est du balad
énigmes donc
ça existe déjà sur dans paris par
exemple pour découvrir un quartier en
résolvant quelques quelques énigmes en
raison des défis et c'est donc on a mis
en place sur l'île de loisirs sa part
une fan belle balade en famille ça dure
près trois heures mais une fois vous
avez livré vous pouvez très bien faire
la moitié revenir plus tard et puis vous
devez trouver des photos mystères
résoudre des énigmes etc et on met en
valeur tout patrimoine à franchir au
mental est historique puisque pour
rappel on a une digue qui date de louis
xiv sur les de loisirs c'est l'occasion
de découvrir différemment ces espaces et
ensuite le week-end prochain il ya
également deux temps forts importants au
centre de voile le 7 mars notamment oui
tout à fait il ya le las la rentrée
sportive de la voile vraiment bat son
plein à partir du 7 mars avec les
premières régates
donc effectivement je vous invite à
aller découvrir donc elle a coûté des
arbitres qui aura lieu à ce moment là et
les régates du club du cpsq le club de
voile de saint quentin vous pouvez très
bien vous allez regarder envoie des
images à les regarder aller observer ça
et c'est vraiment vraiment sympa c'est
un sport qu'on n'a pas forcément
l'habitude de connaître donc c'est
vraiment tactique et
essai ouvert aux spectateurs les deux
compétitions oui tout à fait sur le sur
les bords vous pour aller sur les bords
de saône de vol pour observer s'en est
alors le dimanche 8 mars ça se passe au
centre équestre par contre oui donc pour
ceux qui connaissent déjà et qui sont
inscrits au centre équestre qu'on a
quatre cent vingt adhérents à l'année on
a maintenant de nouvelles
infrastructures de belles
infrastructures on a un manège couvert
on a une grande carrière de 60 par 80
qui nous permet maintenant d'accueillir
des compétitions départementales des
concours complet et c'est donc donc
c'est vraiment très sympa avant cuisson
et une terrasse au-dessus du club house
qui permet d'observer est vraiment de
regarder toute cette compétition donc
c'est quelque chose que je vous invite à
faire on a fait une petite buvette était
assez conviviale et c'est ce sport et
c'est impressionnant l'équitation en
compétition
impressionnant est également le week-end
prochain pour un petit peu d'avancé le
cirque zavatta s'installe à lille de
loisirs oui donc qui viennent pour pour
six représentations donc sur le week-end
le samedi et le dimanche donc le
l'article sera sur le site internet
d'ailleurs je vous invite à aller voir
un site internet de l'île de loisirs
régulièrement parce qu'on y mette toutes
les actus tous les événements dont qui
viennent avec des représentations le
samedi et le dimanche et ensuite je
n'aurais une le mercredi le vendredi et
deux à nouveau le week-end d'après
d'autres événements importants au mars
peut-être alors oui notamment on sera
présent sur le salon destinations nature
et le sens d'un contrat lui qui a lu à
porte de versailles donc on donne des
invitations donc si vous voulez vous
vous rendez à l'accueil de loisirs pour
en récupérer et on organise le départ de
l'eco-trail donc faut savoir que c'est
la deuxième plus grande course nature et
d'europe 2000 personnes qui vont courir
de l'île de loisirs jusqu'au premier
étage de la tour eiffel 80 kilomètres à
près de 80 kg ms ils font encore le
premier étage la tour eiffel mais c'est
vrai que c'est un des parcs qui est
impressionnant à voir mon départ à 12h30
le samedi 21 très bien mérite quoi faire
a dû de loisirs et donc lui base de
loisirs attention merci vincent couteau
d'être venu sur notre trio eh bien nous
on reste dans la nature direction
rambouillet à présent pour les vacances
la bergerie nationale organise des
activités pour les enfants samedi et
dimanche après midi créer son propre
déguisements se perfectionner au
dressage des animaux il y en a pour tous
les goûts depuis deux ans le cirque est
à l'honneur florame parfait et elodie
one
les stars de la journée se sont elles
ces oies ont été dressés et elles font
le spectacle pour le plus grand bonheur
des enfants
le petit troupeau partage la vedette
avec les ânes dans un spectacle sur le
thème du cirque où les enfants jouent
les apprentis dresseur j'ai pris un mal
et puis j'ai fait un parcours
était difficile c'était comment c'était
facile c'était assez facile s'il était
têtue com comment comme emule
faire découvrir les animaux de la ferme
autrement aux enfants c'est l'objectif
de la bergerie des eaux apprivoiser ça
ne se voit pas tous les jours qu'on est
seul souvent utilisé dans le dressage
des chiens de berger ria pas forcément
d'animal plus facile à dresser car notre
c'est un travail très long et même
parfois on travaille dès la naissance
nos animaux notamment des animaux
pédagogique on les élève dès le plus
jeune âge en présence des visiteurs donc
c'est un ennemi qui sont facilement
manipulables
honohan sont manipulés tous les jours en
présence des enfants c'est pour ça aussi
qui sont sympas pour les vacances
scolaires des ateliers magie
déguisements et jeux sont également
proposées jusqu'à la fin de la semaine
il y avait mal de choses donc là c'est à
savary varie les plaisirs entre les
petits spectacles entre
des animaux ils peuvent les toucher les
caresser c'est vraiment savoir ils sont
ravis ils sont tout crotté et c'est
génial
c'était super on est venu spécialement
pour ça oui c'est très sympathique un
petit peu de tout pour les enfants ils
ont bien apprécié là pour tous les âges
trois ans cinq ans de très sympathique
avec ses 300 moutons c'est 50 vaches ses
chevaux et chaque saisie des petits
nouveaux la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet a accueilli plus de cent
mille visiteurs chaque année
et si vous avez la main verte voilà une
activité qui vous intéressera eng 2 fois
aux passionnés de jardins et de
plantations anime des ateliers et des
rencontres et ce samedi 28 février à
elancourt elle propose une activité de
taille fruitière gratuite pour les
adhérents de son association jardin
passion partage pour les non-adhérents
10 euros de participation sont demandés
pensez à réserver car chaque atelier est
limité à 10 personnes et du côté de
magny les hameaux un atelier poterie est
organisée ce samedi de 14 heures à 18
heures l'association pour le rayonnement
du site de port royal vous propose de
vous initier aux différentes techniques
et de travail et la sculpture la terre
le matériel et le four pour faire vos
cure cuire vos pieds sont à disposition
rendez vous au musée national de port
royal des champs et enfin pour les
gourmands une grande chef vous propose
de mettre la main à la pâte
équipé de poche à douille de perles en
sucrée de colorants alimentaires les
enfants s'amuseront à décorer des sables
et rendez vous ce dimanche 1er mars à
france miniature dès 13h30
la 52e édition du salon de l'agriculture
a lieu en ce moment même porte de
versailles et ce jusqu'à dimanche sept
cent mille visiteurs sont attendus pour
cet événement et sur les stands des
agriculteurs et des producteurs évinois
sont venus défendre leur produit et
faire la promotion du département
florane parfait et willem à elles les
ont rencontrés pour nous
une journée au salon de l'agriculture ce
n'est pas de tout repos une véritable
aventure entre les concours de fromages
et de goût 20 on peut même déguster une
glace guînoise les sorbets ou un succès
fou ouais un bon petit corner pendant
les années c'est vraiment top des glaces
mais aussi des confitures des jus et des
pâtes de fruits c'est la première fois
que la ferme du logis situé près de
thouars y est présente au salon de
l'agriculture pour présenter ses
produits on se fait connaître bon c'est
vraiment super on vend nos produits on
vend les produits dérivés de la
cueillette mais ce qu'on voudrait
vraiment c'est donner l'adresse de notre
ferme au champ et on dit que c'est les
yvelines c'est le poumon vert de la
région parisienne et il faut que tout le
monde que tout le monde le sache pour
les agriculteurs yvelinois c'est aussi
l'occasion de croiser des têtes connues
et même de décrocher et quelques
récompenses
tous les ans on présente nos produits
avec quand même plutôt des bons
résultats tous les ans donc
régulièrement on a des médailles sur
différents produits et cette année on a
une médaille d'argent sur le yaourt à la
framboise donc on est assez content
parce que c'est un produit qui avait
jamais été médaillés donc ça permet
d'avoir plusieurs produits médaillés sur
sur toute la gamme comme la ferme de
grignon à plaisir la ferme de viltain
proche de jouy en josas est habitué du
salon de l'agriculture
l'établissement est réputée pourtant pas
question de manquer cet événement
décisif pour agrandir sa clientèle
agriculture d'abord la présentation ce
que tout le monde voit des plus beaux
animaux de toute la france et aussi
c'est un contact et ben de tous nos
clients qu'on peut avoir alors voyez
quand on les reçoit je capte pas mon
tablier j'ai prendre ma veste
d'abord parce qu'il fait froid dehors
pour les accueillir on fait une très
belle visite
du salon je leur présentais avec des
animaux et puis on finit sur nos stands
avec un petit jus de pomme de la ferme
une véritable opération séduction pour
la dizaine de producteurs et
agriculteurs évinois présents sur le
salon pour les retardataires l'édition
2015 fermera ses portes le dimanche 1er
mars
florame parfait notre journaliste
économique qu'est michael et demi
d'euros notre journaliste sportif nous
ont rejoints sur notre plateau bonjour
alors on parlera sport dans quelques
instants mais tout d'abord revenons sur
ce salon de l'agriculture alors flora me
vous y étiez à la rencontre de ses
producteurs événement que l'on vient de
voir votre reportage vous avez pu
écouter quand même à quelques
spécialités wioland n'ont plus goûté à
quelques spécialités des produits yves
binois nous avons goûté les pâtes de
fruits les sorbets que vous avez vues
dans le reportage de la ferme du logis
et surtout aussi les yaourts donc de la
ferme de grignon mais aussi de la ferme
de viltain c'était la seule l'illinois
présents sur le salon non ils ne sont
pas les seuls chinois qui sont présents
sur ce salon mais je vous l'accord ils
sont pas très nombreux si vous y allez
ce week-end par exemple vous pourrez
également rencontrer la jeune société y
propose aussi des produits laitiers
artisanaux ou encore pour les gourmands
je conseille le stand les fleurs dargaud
à qui fait aussi des macarons artisanaux
il ya aussi les légumes du maraîcher
star fabrice robert faut peut-être les
goûters il fournit les légumes pour le
célèbre restaurant la tour d'argent à
paris donc c'est l'occasion de découvrir
sa production des légumes rares et sur
les stands potager de paris et
d'ile-de-france est justement un
yvelinois s'est distingué cette semaine
oui alors mardi au salon de
l'agriculture nous avons assisté aux
épreuves finales du concours du meilleur
ouvrier de france a class fromagers nous
avons suivi un candidat ludovic guillot
il est rambolitains il faisait partie
des dix finalistes et il a été consacré
meilleur ouvrier de france ils n'ont été
que deux d'ailleurs à obtenir ce titre
lui et un autre fromage est originaire
de franche comté alors vous l'avez
rencontré le lendemain comme en est at
il alors oui nous sommes allés dans sa
boutique le lendemain pour le féliciter
pour le rencontrer alors ils étaient
épuisés mais vraiment très très fier de
son titre faut savoir qu'en fait ce
titre donc de mof meilleur ouvrier de
france c'est la plus haute qualification
accordé un d'artisans et depuis 2014 les
fromagers ont aussi le titre d'artisan
maintenant pour la suite il va être
ambassadeur donc de sa profession il va
participer à des éléments de prestige et
représentait aussi les fromages et un
petit peu sur la scène médiatique et
enfin d'un point de vue personnel c'est
la veille donner une certaine renommée
je pense que bientôt il va y avoir
beaucoup de monde qui va se bousculer
dans sa fromagerie à rambouillet est
alors donc le concours a lieu mardi à ce
qu'il ya de casque est prévu pour ce
week end alors il ya plusieurs
événements de prévu si les concours des
meilleurs ouvriers de france vous
intéresse samedi il y en a un de 7
heures à 16 heures donc c'est les
épreuves film finale du concours du
meilleur ouvrier de france mais cette
fois primeur donc ça se déroule dans le
1 et je vous conseille vraiment d'y
aller car c'est assez spectaculaire à
voir les candidats font des oeuvres
exceptionnelles avec leurs produits et
puis il a une super ambiance vraiment ça
vaut le coup bon alors je le rappelle le
salon ferme ses portes ce week end vous
avez jusqu'à dimanche 19h pour vous y
rendre compte et 13 euros l'entrée tarif
réduit pour les moins de 12 ans et
gratuit pour les moins de 6 ans merci
florane pour toutes les informations
tous vos reportages complets d'ailleurs
sont à retrouver sur le sur le site de
tv fils dans votre émission économique
filets qu on passe maintenant à
l'actualité sport du week end
alors michael quels sont les rendez vous
sportifs à ne pas manquer ce week end
alors bonjour yolaine nous sommes donc
en période de vacances scolaires donc il
n'y a pas beaucoup de matches mais
rassurez vous les amateurs de sport
pourront quand même trouvé leur bonheur
ce week-end donc il y aura du basket le
chesnay-versailles affronte ce samedi à
20 heures le village sport basket pour
le compte de la 17e journée de nationale
3 a rencontré programme est programmée
au gymnase mont boron les yvelinois
doivent impérativement l'emporter pour
rester en vie dans ce championnat de
nationale 3 ils sont pour l'instant à
vendre avant derniers avec seulement 19
points trappage ont également sur le
cadre national 3 c'est ça également
nationale 3 donc trappe de son côté doit
également s'imposer sur le terrain de
gennevilliers ça va être très compliqué
pour les hommes de mustapha el hafidi
ils sont également ils sont septièmes du
classement les trafics sont donc dans le
ventre mou ils devront affronter
gennevilliers qu pluie l'équipe occupe
elle la deuxième place du classement
donc cette 17e journée s'annonce
passionnante au fédéral 3 versailles
jouera ce week end aussi il ya également
donc de la fédérale 3 les versailles
reçoivent lagrange d'armentières ce
dimanche à 15 heures au stade de
porchefontaine logiquement le club
présidé par l'emblématique olivier nero
9 devrait s'en sortir sans souci face à
un club qui n'a engrangé que 7 petits
points depuis le début de la saison
versailles n'espère plus grand chose
dans ce championnat à trois journées de
la fin du championnat les hommes de
mathieu quéval sont à neuf points du 4e
on le savait c'est une année de
transition pour versailles des jeunes
joueurs le club prépare déjà la saison
prochaine et du cross-country c'est ça
il y aura également du cross-country ce
week-end dans les yvelines ce sera le
temps fort du département pour ce
dernier week-end des vacances ces
championnats de france ont organisé sur
l'île de loisirs du val de seine aux
mureaux on regarde tout de suite à la
bande annonce
donc vous l'avez vu yolaine 3700 sportif
et 13000 spectateurs donc seront
attendus pour l'événement les conditions
s'annoncent assez chaotique il faudra
seulement sept petits degrés et il
devrait pleuvoir 60 découragera pas les
plus motivés j'en suis sûr j'espère
également en paix tant que maintenant un
rendez vous à ne pas manquer enfin donc
oui vous le disais il y aura la paix
tant que ce samedi à elancourt la
compétition baptisée la boule élan
courtoise est organisée ce samedi de 14h
à 20h au parc des sports guy boniface
une centaine de participants sont
attendus pour l'événement le public est
invité à encourager les compétiteurs
merci voilà au caire les rendez vous
sport du week end très bien version vous
retrouve lundi prochain à 18h30 dans le
7 mai sport tout de suite place à
l'actualité cinéma
c'est la tradition vous le savez comme
tous les vendredis voici les sorties
ciné de la semaine les avis des
spectateurs au micro d' elodie yuans que
s'était plaint à qui on est
c'est des trucs moi j'ai bien aimé
beaucoup d'action moi je suis plutôt
génération casimir mais c'est vrai
chevalier zodiac c'était très
intéressant c'était bien
même si il y avait un peu bu vous allez
quand même des choses romantiques
si quelque chose les volants parfois
moins le début est très bon film
d'animation en espérant qu'elles chutent
c'était super les cascades et son bien
et beaucoup d'action en france à mon
film est un bon film d'action
on rapporte grimpeur et aura par apple
avec les yamakasi ou pas mal mon action
qui suit bien
bon dénouement à la fin c'est vraiment
très bien c'est un très bon film voilà
d'émotion
ça joue entre le fantastique le pur
réalisme s'additionner vachement bien
donc il ya de super image je trouve et
je trouve que l'histoire elle est
magnifique quand même c'est pas mal un
moment c'était un peu un peu triste dans
mon film
et on poursuit avec le coup de coeur de
la semaine au cinéma espace philippe
noiret cette semaine à l'espace public
m'aurait nous vous présentons notre coup
de coeur papa ou maman on vous a réuni
ce soir pour vous annoncer son divorce 1
ils divorcent et 20 tout faire pour ne
pas avoir la garde des enfants voici le
pitch du film ils se sont florence et
vincent leroy modèle de réussite sociale
et conjugale jusque dans leur manière
très civilisée d'annoncer leur
séparation a déjà mis tout se gâte
lorsque leurs trois enfants sont mises
au parfum et qu'on propose aux pères
comme à la mer une promotion à
l'étranger le couple se déclare alors la
guerre travail magic si on n'avait pas
vu avec total suspecte a dit sa non
sélection c'est ça tu veux tu veux la
guerre mais apparemment ce qui va bien à
moi je veux la guerre tu veux dire ah
oui j'avais là dans les cheveux la
guerre civile
jade est courant
tant les quais staff et c'est bien ce
qui est trop oui mais ça allège chantage
sabotage d'une fête lancée de yaourts
les parents déchaînés se lance dans un
jeu de massacre régressif le couple
marina foïs et laurent lafitte assure
dans la surenchère
de mon coeur je mets un
une comédie dynamique drôle et sortant
des sentiers battus on ne va pas bouder
notre plaisir
une dernière info au cinéma elle
concerne le film d'abderrahmane sissako
timbuktu le film aux sept césar dont le
césar de la meilleure musique originale
elle est signée notamment de fatoumata
diawara qui est aussi comédienne dans le
film la chanteuse se produira en concert
le dimanche 8 mars au scarabée de la
verrière je vous propose d'écouter une
des chansons du film
courrier mais vincent
mal
aimé
c'est au temps mort tous viennent faso
des mineurs
paris un bout attends moi toi
c'est à sidi a tous très mal et vas y
et alors
façon
bayer mollit pas aimé ça y est
non
il
n'est pas
il ne vous reste plus beaucoup de temps
pourront profiter l'exposition artistes
d'ici d'emmanuel 'merci' ans de muller
se termine ce samedi 28 février
l'artiste que nous avions reçues en
plateau présente une série de diptyques
où elle mêle art figuratif et art
abstrait rendez vous à la médiathèque
saint-exupéry de voisins-le-bretonneux
une autre exposition se termine ce
week-end deux mille et une tête de yuki
chinois est accessible jusqu'à dimanche
le sculpteur contemporain né au japon
consacre son oeuvre à la taille de la
pierre d'okinawa c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de nous avoir suivis je
vous souhaite un excellent week-end sur
tf1